hi everybody
hi steve it's been a long time it's been
a long time
first because many of my viewers don't
know you could you perhaps introduce
yourself and also uh tell us a little
bit about the polyglot conference in
brno
i was born in the czech republic
and uh i don't know if i can call myself
a hollywood way i love but i love
languages um
an ice hockey teacher for czech
and i'm a neural language coach as well
and
yes i love languages
and i organize a conference
which is
not only for polyglots but for students
for teachers
and it's about language learning
and
it's also for polyglots and i
like polyglots a lot so i invited many
polyglots but you couldn't come so i'm
very sorry that i can't make it well as
it turns out i had agreed to be in
bratislava uh
so i can't be flying back and forth to
europe every couple of weeks you see
uh by the way you said you were born in
the czech republic that tells you it
tells us how old you are
or at least you're no older no
i'm saying i was born in the czech
republic but it was chicken
i know no i'm just just kidding here you
see
okay she's no older than
anyway
no no no okay
uh uh what was i going to say so the
conference how many uh how many people i
see only richards is going to be there
if i'm not mistaken yes i'm so excited
about that
guy he is a great guy he's doing great
work and he's a very helpful very good
guy you're going to enjoy having him at
your conference
how many people do you expect
probably about 115
uh-huh yeah 200 is max and mostly from
the czech republic or from some of the
neighboring countries
uh also there will be if you i don't
know if you know her but probably yes
lydia
oh yes she's excellent i've seen some of
her videos yeah super no i'm really
excited about the speakers and
uh so people from bratislava from
slovakia are coming as well and i know
that some people's for example from
spain or from romania will be there but
the the conference will be half english
half check so like on purpose i didn't
want to translate or to have any
interpreter so it's for people who can
speak english but who can speak czech as
well okay
you know speaking of speaking czech of
course uh i spent about a year
maybe i can't remember the years go by
so quickly now but i think maybe
2012 or so i spent a year on check
listening and reading
my statistics that link show that i my
passive vocabulary is like 60 000 words
now bear in mind that in slavic
languages
for every one word you get 10 because
there's so many different forms right
uh and i listened to you know uh
you know
tolkiesko minilosti on you know czech
radio fabulous fabulous series so i
discovered
check check not czech republic czech
lands the history from the 30 years war
to you know the the revival of czech
nationalism in the 19th century and all
this kind of stuff through the language
had a fabulous time but then i haven't
done much and then we were i was in the
czech republic when we last met in brno
in 2014 and since then i haven't spoken
i occasionally read czech news articles
which i import into link and save any
words that i don't know i sometimes
listen to yaktovidi
on czech radio
yaktovidi which used to have transcripts
but they no longer provide transcripts
which is kind of unfortunate
so i want to speak to you and check but
i really haven't spoken since brno so
i'm curious to see
uh how i do however i have been working
on like i did of my slavic languages i
did russian first
and then czech
and then ukrainian and then polish and
of course with each slavic language it
becomes easier
because they're very similar in many
ways
and i think that having studied
ukrainian and polish now
that my check
will be better it may not be better
right away but it will be better because
in studying these other slavic languages
in fact i'm reinforcing
my hold on check
and i also believe that if we study
through massive input lots of listening
and reading
that that stays inside us in the brain
somewhere so it's just a matter of of
kind of
getting it out there again so
it'll be interesting to see how that
goes
um so
and which languages do you speak
i studied at the university i studied
german to be a teacher of german right
and then i went to the united states so
i learned english of course right and uh
i
i was the annual challenge participant
for russian
so i tried to learn russian right
because i thought it would be different
from the slavic language but what i am
now doing i'm learning french
but i'm not good at russian or french
really
okay the uh yeah it's interesting
a lot of people don't know this like if
if you take a czech person
who has never heard russian which might
be difficult because but maybe younger
people who have never heard russian and
they hear russian for the first time how
much do they understand
well it's funny because i thought i
would understand like 80 percent
but it's like five percent i know it's
disappointing but it's not that it
it's still different language but
if you get used to it quickly in 14 days
you can understand more and more and
more and if you understand the
conversation it's quite easy and you can
speak very fast right but it's not like
when you hear it for the first time so
you think that you would speak and you
would understand but it's not like
has a positive connotation in check
yes it's like wonderful but in question
yes yes it's horrible yes so these are
the problems that we have what about
when you listen to polish let's say it
again a czech person who has no
experience with polish they hear polish
for the first time do they understand
you get the idea you get the idea okay
i heard someone said that that slovak is
the language that is most easily
understood by all slavic speakers that
is somehow the most neutral
can that be
i guess it's hard for you to say
yeah oh like for me yes it's really hard
because i grew up being bilingual
actually yes with the
language with slovak tv oh really okay
yes so
you know uh
slovaks understand 100 of check and vice
versa is that true i think i think they
do because they still have some tv that
it's only in check right because they
are smaller nations so they do not
dump everything they do
[Music]
um
um
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
mom
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
foreign
hello i think we're frozen here
[Music]
anyway we'll finish off in english here
no
i know like i haven't spoken czech right
and so i'm sometimes searching in there
is this is this ukrainian is this czech
is this russia whatever they're like
no this is
check but you know one thing i believe
and maybe that's something that we can
finish up with here is i think when you
speak languages and i'm sure you'll
agree
you have to trust yourself
you have to trust yourself you have to
trust that something will come out that
may not always be right but just go with
it you know go with it if i'm saying
geez i haven't spoken check in a few
years and i'll get it all wrong and is
this right or is that right forget it
maybe i said something that was polish
or ukrainian russian it doesn't matter
you have to trust yourself and and
you're gonna it's like riding a bicycle
you can't be thinking about what do i do
on this bicycle or swimming you just
have to trust yourself and and i think
that if you learn a language through
massive input and this is why my
romanian basically i had two months
before i went to romania that's just not
enough i mean with check i spent a whole
year
if my statistics at links say that i
have 60 000 words that doesn't mean that
i have all these words but it's an
indication of the amount of reading and
listening that i did in czech and if you
ingest so much of the language it's not
going to go away
that's that's that's my opinion
anyway well listen i agree with you
especially conferences i i wish you a
very
successful conference i'm sorry that i
can't be there are you going to be in
bratislava by the way
i hope so okay
yes
good and i hope i know you have a little
bit of a cold and your kids have a cold
so i hope that you all get well soon and
um
thank you for this
how do you say you're welcome again i
can't approach him no
the answer is
okay bye for now
[Music]
you